- Nico! Komm und spiel mit!
- So.
Also, es gibt vier Teams:
Team Osten, Team Süden,
Team Westen und Team Norden.
- Team Süden!
- Süden?
- Hier! Das ist Süden, das ist Norden,
das ist Osten und das ist Westen.
- Hi, ich bin Nico.
Ich komme aus Spanien … aus Sevilla.
- Spanien … das ist im Süden, oder?
Im Süden von Europa.
- Ja. Und Sevilla ist
im Süden von Spanien.
Und du?
- Ich bin Selma.
Ich komme aus Syrien … aus Damaskus.
- Damaskus, das ist …
- Damaskus ist auch im Süden.
Im Süden von Syrien.
Komm jetzt!
Wir gewinnen!
- Gewinnen?
- Nico spricht noch nicht so gut Deutsch.
- Wir gewinnen!
- Gewinnen.
Okay, alle: Gewinnen!
- Ja gut, dann fangt ihr an.
- Ja!
- Wir waren gut!
- Kommt, gehen wir tanzen!
- Mama?
Ja, ich komme.
Entschuldigung.